herzlich willkommen leute ist für den
ultimativen test der trainer los angeles
ich hab es helfen so einige trainer tour
nach videos gesehen und irgendwie nicht
in 100 alle oder fast alle total scheiße
sind oder in der großteil ist echt
deswegen habe ich heute ein video
ausgesucht wo ich denke es könnte in
ordnung sein labor nicht groß drum rum
ich habe mir einen baby- bis und
ausgesucht weil ich keine kinder extrem
lustig werden lassen zu testbeginn mache
ist immer noch ernste wir versuchen
nicht zu lachen und normalerweise kann
ich sehr sehr gut
konzentriere ich normalerweise funkt
diese dinge überhaupt nicht lustig aber
es könnte seine die versionen für wii
hat dich bloß nicht
deswegen gerade noch blocken wird zu
solche dinge lustig zu finden also immer
ich videos mit seinen teams weil sonst
ohne scheiß bei jeder einzelne
schwachstellen wusterwitz aber bei
diesem baby videos ihr habt schon
gesehen und hab jetzt bei diesem video
echten fast lassen müssen
meine hoffnung enttäuscht worden sein
könnte sein dass diese ganzen tranche
läuft ist doch scheiße sind inklusive
trainer to love my lovin babywelt 2016
die gesamte menschheit klammert sich an
diesem letzten span font weight watchers
doch witzig sein können komm schon
ich will nicht mit baby sehen was 30 und
krabbelt warum kann es sich um fall wie
das andere
okay das ist aber auch so sagen nach
bescheuert ist jedes kleine baby so
dinge haben einfach so einen verdammt
riesigen schädel im verhältnis zu ihrem
körper sie dass sie besteht aus 40
prozent machen kann schon mal passieren
dass war und was ich dann auch nicht
verstehe warum versuchen die leute ihr
wie ihr so zwingend drei stunden lang zu
machen meint das ding war die ersten 20
sekunden lustig und es geht es einfach
so eine minute weiter ein baby was
umkippt noch ein baby geboren
okay ist auch nicht wird sich wieder so
ein paar leute was ich verstehe diese
beiden babys so die ersten sekunden
waren witzig aber dann dehnt man den
scheiß auf vier minuten aus nach vier
minuten findet das garantiere ich keine
einzige mehr
ähnliche lebensformen auf diesem
planeten mehr witzig garantiert wenn
irgend jemand der mich kennt mich so
sicher einfach mir feierte auf dem tisch
holen anstatt werde ich es in meinem
kopf frage was macht es da junge
videotext obwohl die dass solche
geräusche machen sollte
irgendwann musste das kind mein
besonders groß machen was können babys
essen schlafen umfallen und lachen das
sind wahrscheinlich so aller dinge die
menschen in dem entwickler steigen
glaubt können
wieso alter babys wird wirklich so die
größte scheiße einfach lustig die mutter
des kindes schritt war gerade zum hand
betreuen ausweist aber so manches kind
findet so was wusste ich okay dass du
beweist er weiß die endgültige weiß
trainer traf changes sind einfach nicht
lustig zumindest für mich nicht selbst
mit dieser version die wahrscheinlich
noch am ehesten muss nicht vor heute
habe ich kein einziges mal so wirklich
gerade ich kann mir schon vorstellen
jetzt auch richtig will in die
kommentare schreiben
ich fand das auch nicht witzig er komme
was war das jetzt wer findet diese
videos lustig warum verbreiten die sich
so wirtsleute dass du nicht schreibt
meine kommentare falls ihr das lustige
von hathor in die kommentare und falls
es nicht lustig gefunden habt schreibt
man die kommentare wieso diese videos so
verbreitet werden wenn ich's nicht
lustig finde
und ihr ist auch nicht richtig findet
was ist es dann